So, you want to be a copywriter in 2026?
Well, you need to forget everything that
you've read on Twitter. Last year, I
made over six figures writing copy
working just a few hours a day. And if I
had to start from zero, here are the
exact seven steps that I would do to
build my business from scratch. And the
shocking part is that it has nothing to
do with chasing clients. But more on
that in a second. By the way, I'm Alan
Drau. I've sold over $2 million with my
copy and over 10,000 copywriters study
my work every single day. This is what I
do all day long. Before we dive into the
seven steps, I'm going to be honest with
you. I want to explain why I wouldn't do
client work at all. In the economy that
we live in with AI, client work,
acquisition, things like that, it is so
much better to focus on creator work in
2026 because it takes the same amount of
skill, energy, and effort to build your
own audience online and sell your own
stuff as it does to cold DM a whole
bunch of people who are already
outsourcing their crap to AI. Not only
that, but your creator business
compounds over year where you can get
clients, lose clients, and all that work
is theirs and gone, and you don't have
the assets anymore. You just built a
bunch of stuff for other people. You
stop trading time for money, i.e. they
stop paying you if you stop working for
them. But your creator brand continues
to grow and grow and grow because the
assets you built online. You don't have
to wait for somebody to tell you that
you could start working, i.e. you're
going to take a hundred hours chasing
clients before you even get to write a
single thing. Where in the creator
economy, you can start writing today.
You can open a Substack today. start
sending emails today. The profit margins
are higher. It takes less work to make
the same amount of money. There's so
many variables to where it just doesn't
make sense to be doing client work in
2026. But listen, if this all sounds
crazy to you and you like the
traditional copywriting path, you want
to chase some clients, get those rev
share deals, go for it. Nothing wrong
with that. But it's not what I would do
and it's not what I'm going to teach you
how to do in this video. But if you're
interested in seeing how becoming a
copywriter in the creator economy can
actually give you 10 times the amount of
skills, freedom, and money than doing
client work, then please go ahead and
stay and watch until the end of the
video because what I will break down for
you may just blow your mind. All right,
now that we got that out of the way,
let's get into the sevenstep framework.
The first thing that we need to do, step
one, is build a plan. For this, I like
to steal Simon Synynics why, what, how
structure because this is going to give
us clarity and direction of where to
take our business, where to spend our
time, and what to ignore. For instance,
my why I wake up in the morning because
I want freedom and autonomy and joy from
my business. I want the freedom to do
whatever I want whenever I want. The
autonomy to build the projects that I
love and do the work that I love, and
the joy to really have fun about what I
talk about, what I teach. So that right
there, when I write that down, I can
look at that and be like, hm, well,
client work really wouldn't match that
because I need to build what they want
me to build, write what they want me to
write, work on their schedule. So right
there, just knowing my why. It's a
complete mismatch with client work. So
that's going to give me direction on how
to build my business. The what is the
thing that's going to unlock your why.
And for this instance, let's use a very
flat example. A what could be building a
$10,000 per month digital copywriting
business, working four to five hours a
day. That's a really solid even number.
120 grand a year, solid income, working
four to five hours a day. That's
awesome, right? Most people would see
that and say, "Fantastic. That would
bring me tons of autonomy, freedom.
Enjoy." Excellent. So, now we know
exactly how to unlock our why. But now,
we need to unlock our what? How are we
going to do that $10,000 per month
working four to five hours a day? Well,
the road map on your how is you need to
build an audience online, move that
audience to an email list, and sell that
email list your stuff. Very simple,
right? audience, email, offer. Super
simple. That's our plan. You can take
your why, what, how, and adjust it
however you want, but I'm giving you my
plan for how I would start over. Next is
we need to pick a niche. For picking a
niche, I use a very simple fourp
framework. Passion, problem, person,
profit. So, you have to understand those
four Ps. Passion. What are you
passionate about? What is the thing you
cannot shut up about? If I was
restarting in 2026, I would write a
bunch of things down like, I like
guitar. I like golf. I like watches. You
don't have to be a copywriter writing to
copywriters. You could be a copywriter
talking about your passions. That's the
power of the internet. There's money to
be made talking about anything. Could be
gaming, whatever. Then the problem you
solve, let's go with golf. I love golf.
I'm passionate about golf. Well, what
problem do I solve with golf? Well, I
could teach people how to stop slicing
their driver, how to chip better, how to
hit their irons a little bit longer.
There's a lot of things that I now know
about golf because of my passion and my
practice that I can help and teach other
people. And then person, who is the
person that you solve? Well, if I'm
going to be teaching some golf, I would
be teaching uh golf beginners, people
who have never picked up a club that
maybe want to break a 100 or that want
to hit their driver longer, right?
Beginner golfers would be my market
here. And so now I know I'm talking
about golf. I know the problems I can
solve and I know the people I'm going to
serve. And profit is you just want to
make sure that there are other people in
that niche selling similar offers. A lot
of people look at this as a red flag.
They're like, "Oh my god, the niche is
saturated." No, it means there are
people buying. There are buyers in that
market. If there is no one else trying
to sell what you are selling the way
you're trying to sell it, that is bad.
That means that your offer is untested
and you are risking a lot of time and
effort for probably a lot of donuts,
zeros. But in this case, we know the
golf niche is highly profitable, golf
education. I would rock that niche and I
would make a lot of money writing for
golf. Which leads us to step three is to
go ahead and start writing. Whoa, whoa,
whoa. Hold the brakes. Are we not going
to read some books or something? No.
This is the big mistake that most people
make is they buy a bunch of books, oh
man, and courses and all this stuff and
they're like, I'm going to study this
and blah blah blah, and they end up
doing nothing. They end up reading maybe
half a book. They get overwhelmed.
They're like, I don't understand this.
And they don't do anything. So, what I
like to do is I like to start writing
today. So, what you do is you go to
Substack, you set up your profile, and
you post today. I'm not affiliated with
Substack or they're not paying me to do
this video. I just think it's a great
platform because it has kind of like
this Twitter feed and this email
marketing tool combined. And so you can
actually post on their Twitteresque
feed. It's called notes. And people can
go directly from your notes to your
newsletter and subscribe. So it makes it
seamless for your social media to grow
your email list, which is essential to
our how, right? We're going to build an
audience, grow an email list, and sell
that email list stuff. And so I see this
platform and I say, "Oh, it's a perfect
match for my plan." And if I were doing
it from scratch, I would write three
tweets a day and one long form article a
week. It's probably 30 to 60 minutes of
writing a day, maybe a thousand words.
It gets me on the timeline. I get a long
form authority article, strong email,
call to action in that email. I sell
them some stuff. But my focus with the
writing is to build my email list. You
got to build that list, build that
audience. And you're not going to do
that reading a bunch of books if you're
not writing anything. But that does lead
us to step four, which is study the
masters. You are not the first person to
try what you are trying to do right now.
You're not the first copywriter ever.
You're not the first person in the
creator economy. Which means there are
thousands of people who have spent
thousands of hours and years writing
resources for you to read and get way
ahead than they got way faster. These
resources are called books. These books
are like 20 bucks. I think it's crazy
that most people don't read more books.
So for 20 bucks, you can access the
minds of some of the smartest people in
the world to solve your problems. And
what I'm about to give you is five books
that I would recommend you stop and buy
right now. In fact, I'm going to put the
links in the description below for you
to grab them all. The first book is the
AdWee copywriting handbook by Joe
Sugarman. This is the 101 copywriting
must-read essential banger that every
person should have. I don't want you to
buy a course. I don't want you to buy a
coach, anything like that. Read this
book first. You got to read it and
understand all the copyrightiting
fundamentals. The second book is
Storyworthy by Matthew Dixs. Okay, the
best storytellers are the people who own
the internet. If you just post a bunch
of value post and chat GPT copy post,
that's why the internet is saturated
with a bunch of mediocre creators. The
best creators tell the best stories and
this book will help you tell great
stories. Next is cash advertising by
Drew Whitman. This is a more advanced
copywriting tactics really into
persuasion and sales offers and all the
things that you need to actually make a
ton of money with your brand. But this
shouldn't be read until you read ADW
week copywriting handbook. Then you can
dive into this baby. And then everybody
writes by Ann Hanley. This is super
underrated because most copywriters
under value the art of writing itself.
There's so much emphasis on persuasion
and sales that they do not think about
formatting and tone and structure and
the things that actually make reading
digestible and fun and sticky on the
internet. This is a great one to help
you do that. And then lastly, one of the
best is The Art and Business of Writing
Online by Nicholas Cole. This is like an
a an all-enccapsulating how-to guide of
really building and monetizing your
writing business online. Gives you some
great writing tips. Uh honestly, just
one of the best books you can read ever.
So, now you have those books, but you
already have a writing habit. You're
already writing online. So, while you're
reading one of the books, you may read
something, highlight it, and be like,
"Oh, that's interesting." And now you
can try it with your writing. You can
implement it and be like, "Okay, I'm
going to try that tactic. I'm going to
format my writing. Oh, I'm going to add
this constraint because you have
somewhere to practice what you're
learning. This is what's going to get
you past 99% of people who never start.
And by the way, a bonus resource for you
is a link in the description below is
copywriting catalyst. 63 cash cow
copywriting secrets that I spent over
9,000 hours studying copywriting and put
these together in a condensed form for
you to have. So, you can go grab those.
You can get it today for free. Just put
your email in. it'll send it to you and
that way you could start studying some
serious copywriting tactics to write
explosive copy ASAP. All right, let's
move on to step five. Step five is you
need to make an offer. You need to sell
something. You're you're not going to
make any money until you sell anything.
So, you're writing on Substack. Your
audience is growing. Your email list is
growing. And now we need to sell them
something. But before we know what to
sell, we have to pick a product. Okay?
Is it going to be a course? Is it going
to be a paid newsletter? Is it going to
be a paid community? Am I going to do
coaching? Am I going to sell templates?
Lots of different routes you can go. For
me, I like recurring revenue. It's very
hard to build a business on, you know,
peaks and valleys of revenue. So, I
don't really like to base my business
off courses or anything like that. So,
for this, I'm going to say either a paid
newsletter or a paid community. But, for
the sake of simplicity, let's say a paid
newsletter. So, we're writing in the
golf niche. We're teaching golf content.
We're going to do a golf paid
newsletter, right? Let's say we're doing
a couple emails a week. Substack does a
perfect paid newsletter. So, we pick the
perfect platform to do that. And let's
say we charge $10 a month for our paid
newsletter. Well, let's do some math.
Okay, so let's say you have 5,000
Substack followers and 20% of your
followers become email subscribers. So
now you have a,000 email subscribers.
And 10% of your email subscribers become
paying subscribers. So now you have a
100 paying subscribers. Well, a 100
paying subscribers times your $10 a
month means you're now making $1,000 a
month off your paid newsletter. That is
pretty awesome off just $5,000 followers
working probably a couple hours a week.
But it doesn't hit our goal. We need our
10K per month. Okay. So now let's take
those numbers, those conversion rates,
and let's scale them up. Let's say we
grow our audience to 50,000 followers.
Out of those 50,000, 20% convert into
email subscribers. So now we have 10,000
email subscribers. 10% of those email
subscribers become paying subscribers.
So now we have a,000 paying newsletter
subscribers. 1,000 paying subscribers at
$10 a month is 10 grand a month. So now
what we're looking at is building an
audience of 50,000 subscribers and
hitting those conversion rate. Which
leads me to step number six, which is
ruthlessly create content. Content is
your lead magnet machine. It is how you
grow your email list. And the more you
grow your email list, the more people
will buy your offer. So that is how you
scale beyond the 1,000 people buying
your $10 offer is you actually start
doing things like writing more tweets.
Go from three to five, writing more
articles, go from one article a week to
three articles a week or actually
repurposing your content across multiple
platforms. So all those articles that
you've been writing, you could turn them
into Twitter threads or um Instagram
threads, LinkedIn, Tik Tok, you could be
podcasting, you could put them on
YouTube. There's all kinds of things
that you could do to now get your
newsletter out into other platforms,
which then grows your email list and you
could sell more of that $10 paid
newsletter to a lot more people. So
a,000 people becomes 2,000 people
becomes 10,000 people paying you. And
all of this in the same amount of time
that it took you to write the same email
for the same thousand people, which
means your income will scale without
scaling your time. This is called
leverage. And when you do client work,
you have zero leverage because it takes
the same amount of time to get the same
amount of money. You charge them a
certain amount for a certain amount of
deliverables. I'll charge you a grand a
month for three emails or whatever it
is, and you still have to write those
three emails for the same money. But
with the creator economy, you can create
digital assets that scale without you
always investing time. This is why I
don't understand how in 2026, people are
still trying it the old way, which is
exactly why I started the video the way
I started and exactly why I taught you
the same six steps that I would take to
grow my copywriting business from
scratch. And I do hope you found the
video helpful. And if you did, please
consider liking the video and
subscribing to the channel. That tells
me that you want me to make more content
just like this for you. And don't forget
Copywriting Catalyst 63 Cash Cow
Copywriting Secrets. My free guide is
down in the comments and in the
description below. You could grab it,
put your email in. It's completely free
and it'll give you a huge head start. I
appreciate you watching. Thank you so
much. I hope you enjoyed and I'll catch
you on the next one. Oh my gosh. Can you
imagine like starting in 2026 and you're
like I'm going to cold DM 100 people and
I'm going to I'm going to get that dog
food company. I I really want to write
for that and dude I'm sitting here
writing about I'm like I want to write
about golf and stuff. You're like no I'm
going to talk about that 80% organic
chicken and we're going to it's real dog
food and how many angles can I take
about 20% off 20 oh my god. How many 20%
off emails have we written? How many 20%
off coupons are there? Please. that we
know it's not real dog food. You're
lying.